- Is it true that even
after all that time,
that you still get mistaken
for Mila Kunis? Is that real?
- I do, it still happens.
I mean, I met her maybe 10 years ago.
I was very excited to meet her.
I was such a massive fan and
everyone always told me that I
looked like her.
And, but the first time I
met her, she was like, I,
I get confused as you all
the time. And I love it.
I take it as a compliment
because you're younger than I am.
So sometimes I go along with
it and I was like, well,
the next time that I get mistaken for you,
can I pretend to be you?
And she gave me permission,
but then a month later
it was the Golden Globes
when she was nominated for black Swan.
- Oh my gosh.
Tell them, you totally
acted like you were her.
Please.
- I wanted to so badly, but I was like,
the jokester in me, the like Sagittarius,
just like prankster was
just like, yes I am Mila
and Natalie and I had
a secret relationship
when we were filming and
just start a bunch of rumors.
And then I was like, nope,
Sarah, hold your tongue
for one time in your life.
Hold your tongue. And I just,
I just said, no, thanks.
And walked away.
- I'm gonna be real with
you, that's horrible though.
Like, I know y'all do look
a lot alike, but like,
if you're like interviewing
people on the carpet of the
Golden Globes, you should
know who you're talking to.
Like, that's horrible.
- They were just like screaming at me.
They just thought I was her.
And I was like, oh, these
people want to talk.
Oh, you think I'm Mila? Nevermind.
- Oh my God.
I just know that she's so
much more important than I am
and always will be and
I admire her so much.
- That is not true.
I love that she was complimented
though she was like,
you're younger than me. I'll take it.
So wait, do you have any big
plans for 2021 since 2020
just really sucked.
- Well, I would like to say first is,
I don't think that 2021
is a restart button,
but hopefully some amazing
things project-wise will be
coming out.
I'm definitely going to get
married this year though.
Like, no matter what,
even if it's signing
paperwork on a kitchen table.
I'm getting married this year.
- I know you've had to postpone it, right.
Because of COVID obviously.
- Along with all of the other 2020 brides.
- Yeah. There's been so many.
It was like, I guess somebody
was like it's a lucky year.
And then like, nope.
- Nope, 2020 is hindsight. I guess.
- Someone's behind.
So 2020 was obviously a
dumpster fire for everyone.
But how did you handle it?
Did you, do you get any new,
like hobbies or anything?
- I told myself I was
going to get to new hobbies
and then Netflix happened, and food.
No, I, for me, I've been through,
this is not my first
time quarantining before,
when I've had transplants
in the past afterwards,
you were on such major
immunosuppressants that you had like
a deficit of an immune system.
So I've had to quarantine
before, definitely not this long,
only like three months at a time.
But so for me I was like chilling
with it. I was like, okay,
go with the flow. I've done this before.
But like everybody, you know,
everyone has a limit and there
are times where I feel like
I'm going absolutely insane.
And I feel like I have zero
purpose for life in the sense of
like, what am I supposed to be doing?
I feel like, Nina in
The Seagull, but for me,
I try to find the silver lining in things.
I think 2020 has been
an amazing year for people actually
uniting and standing up for one another,
especially when it comes
to social injustices.
I think that has just been
the highlight of my 2020.
It is so beautiful to not only
witness, but be a part of,
and yeah, I like to
look at silver linings.
I'm also a crazy control
freak. So for me --
- Thar's the Sagittarius by the way.
- Yeah.
Monica Geller.
So I like to,
I like to do things that I at
least have some control over
and I let,
I let myself go a little bit
at the beginning of quarantine.
Cause I was like vacation, I
get to eat whatever I want.
I don't ever have to
wash my face ever again.
And then I realized I'm
still engaged and I had to,
and it was starting to smell.
So I ended up finding amazing
skincare routines and just
something like that really helps me.
I picked up a pen out of nowhere.
- So this is my special
pen. No, but you're right.
Let me, say that because
actually speaking of skincare,
I will say this a lot of
us have felt like crazy,
like in this time.
And I will say like keeping
up some kind of like
regular routine has it's
helpful for like your
mental health too, to not
just completely be like,
so I'm going to stick to just
sweats and never bathing this
whole time because
what's the point of life.